2010neuf n'avaient pourtant pas commencé
sur une si bonne mais donnez chapovalov
s'est ressaisie ya guider le canada
jusqu'à la finale de la coupe davis
une première pour félix auger ali yasin
2019 c'est un bond gigantesque de la
108e à la 17e place mondiale
[Applaudissements]
mais au canada quelqu'un a fait beaucoup
mieux
rien qu'un briscous bat serena williams
en finale des internationaux des états
unis gagne la coupe rogers le tournoi d
indian wells 6 matches d'affilée et
passe de la 152e à la 4e place mondiale
ce qui fait d'elle la canadienne la
mieux classée de l'histoire à seulement
19 ans mr émission aucune chance les
amateurs de baseball retombe en enfance
la comptine berrichonne est la plus
populaire à washington choisit d'abord
comme chansons d'inspiration bâton par
l'un des joueurs des nationals baby shaq
est adoptée par leurs partisans qui la
chante tous en choeur jusqu'à la série
mondiale
j
à saint louis les partisans des blues
préfèrent se tourner vers un être des
années 80
gloria devient la chanson fétiche des
joueurs de la pire équipe de la ligue
nationale de hockey qui après la mort
chanter durant une fête en janvier
deviennent les lauréats de la coupe
stanley un revirement de situation
invraisemblable ma vie
[Musique]
au super bowl le spectacle de la
mi-temps ne s'attire pas d'éloges ni le
match
les béthenyates d'atrium strike droit
c'est le plus bas pointage de l'histoire
du super bowl
[Applaudissements]
un panier magique c'est celui-là de
kauai mais l'inspiration des raptors de
toronto premier avec canadienne
championne de la nba
[Applaudissements]
au canada en 2019 c'est l'année de
mikaël kingsbury double champion du
monde de keirin masse la nageuse qui
défend son titre mondial ou 100 m dos
[Applaudissements]
d'andré de grâce de sprinteurs de retour
parmi les meilleurs de kimbuta
la patineuse de vitesse presque
imbattable et de max part aux
planchistes toujours champions ouais
comment ça
en ce temps des fêtes un peu de
nostalgie 2019 c'est la dernière
descente de l'intéreur de la good gagne
enfin son cinquième tournoi des maîtres
quatorze ans après le quatrième est la
preuve est faite un marathon peut se
courir en moins de deux heures walou
pertinents mais ce qui compte vraiment
c'est d'être capable de franchir la
ligne d'arrivée
jean françois poirier radio-canada
mauvais